momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero luís méndez
louis iniciamos con noticias del
presidente alberto fernández el
presidente argentino que culmina su gira
por europa
así es andrés y culmina reuniéndose con
varias personalidades el día de hoy pero
la que llamó más la atención fue la
reunión que sostuvo con la directora
gerente del fondo monetario
internacional kristalina georgieva
siendo este el primer encuentro entre
ambas personalidades aunque se espera
que a su llegada a buenos aires el jefe
de la casa rosada- ofrezca mayores
detalles de la gira por el momento la
misma según su visión fue calificada
como exitosa
durante el encuentro con joseba
fernández aprovechó plantear algunos
temas que le preocupan como es el caso
de la deuda que mantiene su nación con
este organismo sobre ello la titular de
esta institución multilateral agradeció
el encuentro y sobre ello señaló que
mantendrá el compromiso para ayudar a
argentina a superar sus desafíos pero
escuchemos lo que dijo alberto fernández
tras el encuentro
fue una buena reunión una reunión muy
franca donde nos hablamos con mucha
franqueza
donde expresamos nuestras voluntades
de resolver el problema de la deuda
argentina pero como siempre digo yo
encontrar un camino de solución que no
signifique postergar al pueblo argentino
que le está pasando
todavía muy mal entre la pandemia y una
economía que heredamos que le cuesta
ordenarse luisa de buenas noticias para
la economía colombiana
así es andrés y es que según datos
oficiales el país sudamericano que en
los actuales momentos se encuentra
sumido en una profunda crisis social
expandió su economía en 11 por ciento
durante el primer trimestre del presente
año
el dato que fue ofrecido por el
departamento administrativo nacional de
estadística fue mejor al de las
estimaciones de los analistas que
esperaban una contracción de 1 por
ciento el tiempo que el banco central
del país sitúa la baja en un 0.3 por
ciento el dato supone la primera
expansión económica de la nación en
medio de la pandemia vale recordar que
en 2020 la economía colombiana se
contrajo un 6 8% las estimaciones de
crecimiento para el 2021 se ubican en el
rango entre 3 y un 7% lo llevamos a perú
porque cifras oficiales detallan un
aumento en la tasa de pobreza ésta se
incrementó casi 9 en casi 10 puntos
porcentuales hasta alcanza
el 31% de la población es decir
alrededor de 9 millones 800 mil personas
el informe presentado por el instituto
nacional de estadística e informática
detalla la contracción de 11 12% que
sufrió la economía peruana durante el
año 2020 este informe se impone como un
revés para la nación que desde el año
2001 venía disminuyendo el índice de
pobreza que en aquel entonces entonces
abarcaba un 54 8 por ciento de la
población
este informe refiere que el ingreso real
promedio por habitante también se redujo
en 2 20.8 por ciento hasta alcanzar la
cifra de 220 dólares
louis hay un informe que revela una
reducción en cuanto a la deuda mundial y
es que de acuerdo con el instituto de
finanzas internacionales los pasivos de
gobiernos empresas entidades financieras
y familias de todo el planeta
disminuyeron entre enero y marzo 1.7
billones de dólares a pesar del descenso
de las obligaciones pendientes de todos
permanecen elevadas y por el orden de
los 289 billones de dólares de acuerdo
con el informe la leve caída global en
el primer trimestre responde
fundamentalmente a la mano del descenso
de las deudas de los países ricos este
documento también refiere que brasil y
argentina dos de los grandes países
endeudados en américa latina han sido
los únicos dentro de las economías
emergentes que han registrado descensos
en los niveles de deuda en moneda
extranjera louis como cerraron los
mercados este viernes la jornada cerró
con números positivos tanto en el dow
jones y en el standard and poor's esto
hablando de wall street- sin embargo el
sector tecnológico fue que protagonizó
la mejor recuperación con más de 2
puntos de incremento a pesar de ello
wall street cerró la semana con números
negativos por otro lado en europa hubo
bien buen cierre para las bolsas
impulsadas por el desempeño de wall
street del día de ayer mientras tanto
japón cerró con avances gracias a las
ganancias a los sectores transporte y
bienes raíces en américa latina' los
datos positivos de colombia también
impulsaron las bolsas
también cerró en positivo el mercado
chileno
luís méndez con la información económica
en france 24 muchas gracias por
acompañarnos y ustedes muchas gracias
por sintonizarnos quédense con nosotros
[Música]